what up boys gonna beat ya'll to the
punch I'm gonna expose myself before any
of you guys get the chance no I'm just
kidding honestly I'm doing this video
because I've noticed all the extreme
growth on the channel and that's amazing
and I really appreciate it but honestly
I want to make sure that we catch all
the new subscribers up to speed with
everything because I don't want myself
getting a reputation that I can't live
up to and I want to be clear about what
I do and what I think of myself and what
I don't think of myself real quick so
there are a lot of like memes in this
community like the coffee Zilla army
that people call me Sifu whatever and I
think for new subscribers you might
think that that's not ironic so the
first thing I want to address and just
kind of put in check real quick is you
know this thing about the coffee Zilla
army I kind of joke about that sometimes
and you'll see it in the comments that's
a joke don't think that you're part of
an army and you need to go fight people
and go harass them don't do that I never
encouraged that please just keep it on
this channel I just want to encourage
skepticism and just make sure you guys
don't end up getting scammed right the
other thing is people call this is a
personal favorite of mine
people call me Sifu because that's a
little nickname that Dan Locke made his
followers call him so I called myself
Sifu but it's a joke guys please don't
uh Naomi Sifu I don't mind when you guys
call me that but sometimes I see a
comment and I think to myself oh my gosh
I think that guy actually like really
looks up to me and you shouldn't I
I hate to say that but I'm just a guy on
the internet you know trying to do my
best to help educate people and maybe
give you a laugh and a smile you know
during your day while we do it and last
thing I want to address real quick is
that I will get things wrong okay if you
followed me since my coffee break days
you know that I am very capable of
getting things wrong but you should also
know if you've followed me since those
days that I'm willing to admit when I'm
wrong guys
I try to be anyway and I'm making this
video partially because I know I'm gonna
mess up in the future I'm sure of it
because what I do is inherently
journalistic and when you're doing
journalism you just you can get things
wrong the facts aren't always clear you
don't always have the full story so
I don't want to mess up in the future
and you guys think Oh coffee Zilla was
supposed to be always right but he's not
really always right yeah I know that and
so should you
you guys should realize that I will
eventually get things wrong you guys
shouldn't just blindly believe me
because you'd be making the same mistake
you're making with these gurus you
blindly believe the gurus don't come to
me and then blindly believe me sometimes
I'm gonna be wrong so be aware of that I
mean as an example of when I've gotten
things wrong in the past because I
definitely have I don't know if you guys
remember because I quickly deleted the
video after I realized I was wrong I did
a video about idea pros right and I had
this lawyer on and he talked about why
idea pros was a scam well right after I
posted that video
the CEO of idea pros reached out to me
and he very respectfully said you know
hey would you like to sit down with me
talk with me I think you got me all
wrong you know I love what you're doing
but I think you got me all wrong I ended
up talking to him and he gave me enough
reasons to doubt the story that I had
been told and I had sold on my channel
to where I had to delete the video I had
to say you know what I can't have this
out on the channel so that's gonna
happen guys and you have to understand
that that's why I say any guru can come
on the show it's not just because I like
the debate and they're entertaining
which they definitely are it's because
of the fact when you give people a
platform to defend themselves sometimes
they will and sometimes they'll be right
and you'll be wrong and it's up to me
not to dig in and say no I'm right it's
up to me to say I'm wrong and you know I
can only do that if you guys have a
human perspective of me don't put me on
some pedestal don't believe that I'm
some like Savior of the fake guru space
I'm just a guy telling you that there
are a lot of scams out there hey future
Steven here I just wanted to add I know
that most of you don't see me this way
most of you see me as I truly am some
idiot on the internet giving his opinion
but I've seen like a 5% maybe even if
it's one person of you who do think of
me a little bigger than I am right and
that's who I'm making this video for I'm
not so arrogant to think you a lot of
you have me on this pedestal I'm aware
that most of y'all know it I'm exactly
where I am right like I'm exactly as
dumb as I appear but this is for a small
crowd of maybe new subscribers who
really haven't been here long enough to
kind of know the full situation so with
that said guys thank you so much for
watching
I'm loving all the positivity on the
channel let's keep that going and don't
forget to smash like and subscribe thank
you
[Music]
[Music]
but never sure the trust
[Music]
for the common
[Music]